[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
live from the g7 summit in cornwall
the thing about these big family
gatherings that they always start with
broad smiles and
pleasantries but frankly after drinks
are taken
old animosities can bubble to the
surface
and then things end up in the car park
well
meetings of world leaders are frankly no
different
boris johnson is already fending off
attacks particularly from his
eu colleagues yesterday he said that
they need to get it into their heads
that northern ireland is part of the uk
in the row
over checks in the irish sea but the
irish prime minister
uh miguel martin told sky news that it's
time for the uk to show the will
to end the row well how's it all going
to end
we don't know but we are pretty sure
that there will be smiles
and there will be jokes this afternoon
but they may mask
deeper tensions that will last into the
future
today we've got a bumper lineup to react
to everything that's happened here in
cornwall in just a moment
i'll be joined by the foreign secretary
dominic raab
we'll be hearing from ireland's prime
minister michel martin
with his strong message for boris
johnson
the former uk prime minister gordon
brown will be giving his reaction
to world leaders plans to donate
vaccines to the developing
world labour's shadow international
trade secretary
emily thornberry will be giving her
reaction to the summit
as will the former conservative
international development secretary
andrew mitchell and as the government
prepares to delay the lifting of
lockdown on june the 21st
we'll be hearing from their advisor on
covet and ethnicity
dr raheb ali
but first i'm pleased to say i'm joined
by the foreign secretary dominic
raab foreign secretary good morning now
um
i know it's not over until it's over but
what
can we expect to hear and what do you
hope to hear from the prime minister
uh this afternoon well look the
we've seen the worst crisis probably
since the second world war
and i think if we're all honest a sense
countries have perhaps been going their
own way
and what this g7 summit under the uk
presidency and the prime minister's
uh chairmanship has delivered is a a
global gear shift in international
collaboration
now you're going to get the full
communique at two o'clock just in time
for the football
um but let me just give you a sense of
what's going to be in there we led the
way with
our offer 100 million vaccines from our
surplus domestic supply
we now believe that we've got a
commitment for a billion doses to go to
vaccinating the world by the
middle of next year the current
trajectory had us on the end of 2024
so that is a game changer in dealing
with the pandemic and getting the world
back to normal
on climate change g7 leaders have
previously committed to net zero by
uh 2050. what we've got is a series of
commitments
to harvard missions by 2030 and a whole
range of
uh commitments to not just then coal but
in the finance of coal
so i think you're going to see that
global gear shift and that's what global
britain's all about
we hear the gear shift but honestly
a lot of this probably could have been
done after 18 months where we've done
things by zoom
actually did we need all the ballyhoo to
get that
done i think it was settled before they
all got here
no it hasn't been i could tell you from
my own personal experience with this is
the first net zero g7 summit by the way
so we're talking the talk not just uh
walking the walk not just talking the
talk but actually you do need to get
leaders
around the table if you want to stop
this sort of fragmentation
if you want to see global cooperation if
you want to deliver that global
gear shift in international corporation
which the prime minister
has been at the vanguard of you've got
to get the leaders together let's talk
about the
big issue that's for today and that is
the billion
uh vaccine doses um the head of the who
and also the common secretary
commonwealth secretary general and
others are saying it's really not enough
the number they're looking for
is 11 billion and they want them sooner
isn't this just feeling a bit like a
gesture
rather than a real way of solving the
problem of the developing world
well of course uh the the extra doses
that have been achieved are a billion
but that's two billion in total
uh that the that has been uh uh
committed to by the g7
and we've been leading the way um but
look the let me let me big big gap
between 1 billion
and 11. let me show you let me just
demonstrate for your viewers what that
means
if we carried on the current trajectory
we wouldn't have the world vaccinate
till the end of 2024
and what we've now shifted that if we
can deliver on that which i'm confident
we will today
is that by the middle of next year the
world will be vaccinated that's 18
months difference that is a massive step
change
of course we want to go further and
faster and of course it's worth
remembering that we pioneered 90 million
pounds of taxpayers money
into the astrazeneca vaccine 95
of the kovacs vaccines going to the
poorest countries of the world and now
because of the az
vaccine and because of that investment
the problem is the foreign secretary
is speed it's speed uh
next year isn't going to be fast enough
we're seeing in our own country
we're having to turn on the sixpence
because this thing develops so
fast and come back to what the head of
the who
is saying we need more vaccines
faster and actually giving a billion
fine
but actually it won't stop this thing
getting out of control
shouldn't we really be thinking about
putting more resources in
now and getting more vaccines across to
people
now that's what we're doing i mean the
extra billion comes in now
it expedites more than a billion well of
course it's easy to say at the end of
the summit when everyone said it was
impossible
and we've shifted the dial by 18 months
in terms of world vaccination
say it's not enough i think actually
people understand that is a massive step
change
and it's one where the uk has led the
way and of course we've uh
you know we've got our own domestic uh
roll out we're doing very well
but we've got enough certainty of supply
that we could give 100 million
that has a vaccine of excess vaccines
that has helped galvanize and the prime
minister has been able to say look we're
leading by example
come on join the effort but just very
quick it is a matter of priorities isn't
it you say in the integrated review
document you've published very proud of
that you're outspending
the nato target we're undershooting
our oc's development target the point is
are you getting the priorities right
we're spending more money
on guns perhaps we ought to be spending
more resources in time and getting
vaccines into people's arms well look i
i don't think it's a zero-sum game a lot
of the work we do for example i've seen
in east africa
training uh countries like the the
peacekeepers to put out
uh explosives uh improvised explosive
devices that
al shabab elect are also about
development i don't think there's a
zero-sum game
in terms of development i mean actually
the third thing i was going to point to
is what we're doing on girls education
the prime minister has been driving
40 million more girls into 12 years
education we have put the biggest
contribution
into the global partnership for
education 430 million i think you'll see
in the communique
billions extra coming from other
countries to hit that target i want to
come back to that but
let me just uh ask you about what the
prime minister of
ireland has been saying this this
morning told sky news that a practical
arrangement on northern ireland could be
reached
yet the prime minister yesterday said
that he was ready to invoke article 16
of northern ireland protocol essentially
putting a stop and that's it's pretty
belligerent
isn't it when the irish are saying let's
make a deal
you're the chief diplomat for the
government are you going to be telling
the prime minister when he speaks this
afternoon
call it and the prime minister's been
very calm but also firm about this
what we've seen article 16 is a bit
previous so let me answer the
the challenge that you rightly make
we've seen a very lopsided approach to
the northern ireland protocol which is
supposed to protect
all communities in northern ireland not
just the eu equities but also on
article six you'll be familiar with it
the free flow of trade and goods between
northern ireland and great britain that
hasn't happened fully
one in five of all of the eu checks and
controls to protect its border from
central and eastern europe through
around to the south of the
of the continent up to northern one in
five takes place in orlando that cannot
be right
so what we want is a more proportionate
flexible approach if mijo martin is
willing to press the commission on that
fantastic we want tensions eased
we want a flexible pragmatic approach
what we cannot have
is both the northern ireland protocol
being applied in a very lopsided way
or the good friday agreement being
undermined as a result of it you're
talking about the way it's applied but
let's let's
just get back to basics you sign the
thing
then the eu is sticking to the letter of
the deal they're not no
now you're saying now you're saying
let's let's be a bit more practical
let's be a bit
bit more flexible why did you sign the
deal in the first place that's an
inaccurate this was coming
trevor that was that's an inaccurate
characterization of course
the northern ireland protocol is a
package it's got bits uh to protect the
eu equities
it's got bits to protect the free flow
of goods between great britain northern
ireland for example
trade facilitation under article six the
problem is
the commissioner insisting on a very
lopsided purist approach
if we have a sensible pragmatic flexible
approach and we put
loads of proposals to the other side if
they're now in a position to come back
and show the
flexibility because you know when this
happens in northern ireland
it has real life effects on the
communities and the businesses there
okay
let me stop you there your colleague
lord frost says it's legalistic
by which he means it's what's down there
in the paper
and you're saying it's purist but it is
the deal you want it to operate in a
different way
for what it says on the paper and that
might be perfectly reasonable but you've
got to accept the eu
are not in the wrong in saying this is
what we agreed
why don't you stick to it trevor your
assumption and premise i'm afraid is
flawed i've given you one example
article 6
which talks about free-flowing trade
between measures to facilitate the free
flow of trade
between britain and northern ireland
there's many others and the the truth is
the northern ireland protocol was a
compromise what we need is both the
letter and the spirit to be respected
we've come up with proposals we've given
them to the commission uh what we cannot
have is the continuing
disruption of trade and effectively
trying to change the status of northern
ireland
contrary to the wishes or the consent of
the people which is not just contrary to
the northern ireland protocol but also
the belfast agreement
let's stick with the diplomacy issue um
is it right that president macron
said that northern ireland was not part
of the united kingdom
and the he was rebuked by the prime
minister well i well i don't do
as a matter of diplomatic
professionalism come out and spill the
beans what i can tell you is no one
should be surprised by
these reports and it's not just one
figure we have seriously seen senior eu
figures
talk about northern ireland as if it was
somehow different country from the uk
that is not only offensive it has real
world effects on the communities north
london
creates great concern great
consternation but also trevor could you
imagine if we talked about catalonia
the flemish part of belgium one of the
lander in germany
northern italy corsica and france as
different countries
we need a bit of respect here and also
frankly an appreciation
of the situation for all communities in
northern ireland
yeah but uh let's come back again to the
same point you signed the deal
and why would they not think that way
well the deal has
countless provisions protecting all
sorts of equities
you're shifting the gold posts again
secretary let me answer let me answer
because i i accept the challenge that
you're putting down
but in a deal which has a package
reflecting provisions that
protect eu equities but also protect uh
the integrity of the uk
both sides of that deal must be
implemented our challenge back to the eu
is you're doing this in a lopsided way
if they want to now come to the table
with flexibility goodwill and pragmatism
we would love to see this issue
resettled because for us the key issue i
missed some of the ignorant comments
that have been made
about northern ireland what else really
matters is the businesses from all
communities the livelihoods the
the the the sense of consternation
anxiety in communities
on all sides in northern ireland we need
to give them that reassurance this is
all about leadership um
does it show great leadership for the
world's
leaders to gather at a barbie
where there are more than 30 people more
than a limit
that ordinary people will be able to
have at their weddings and where the
only people
wearing masks were the staff
now i can understand that there will be
all sorts of
precautions and so on but it's not a
good look is it
look it's outside you can see it's very
well ventilated on the
on the beach we've done we've taken if i
have a wedding i can only have 30 right
inside our outside in fairness trevor
both in terms of
the checks that have been done the daily
checks for covid
um the the precautions the slimline
delegations we have taken
every measure possible to make sure this
is not just uh
kobit secure but able to take place and
i think we've gone
well beyond and above in terms of make
sure making sure
that this is covered secure so um it's
pretty good signal that if you're having
a wedding and you can have it outside
you can probably have more than 30
people and uh not wear a mask
well the g7 is not 30 people but there's
more than 30 people at the bbq the
pictures are all out there
there was social distancing that that
they were not
social distancing well you know trevor
we we look
very carefully honestly i i'm not
blaming you for this foreign secretary
all i'm saying is it's out there
and actually maybe somebody tripped up
maybe somebody made a mistake
but it's out there and people will be
reasonably saying
you're not allowing me to gather with my
friends and family at a wedding or a
funeral
but look at what you guys are doing in
fairness uh there have always been
different
uh principles for social entertainment
or weddings than for government business
now you may make uh light of barbecues
powerful
no no no those rules have been the same
all along okay but i think people will
understand i think your viewers will
understand the serious business
of bringing leaders together to bring
back the economy stronger
greener deal with the pandemic shift the
point at which
the whole world is vaccinated from 2024
to the middle of um
uh next year that's a serious business
that they're engaged in
amidst all of the uh the leisure
activities on the beach straightforward
question
21st of june will restrictions be lifted
or not
well did you know the prime minister
will set out the proposition tomorrow
we're in a race against if you like to
roll out the second dose of the vaccine
against the variance we need to assess
the data very carefully we've done a
great job with this vaccine rollout but
as the pm
said we want to proceed irreversibly and
that means we need to do it carefully
and cautiously
so it feels like we're in a realm where
we could be backing i can't account for
the value i feel this morning but i can
tell you that you'll get the full
answers tomorrow
let's talk about the harry dunn case
have you given up on the possibility of
ann
sakulas the american diplomat or
diplomat's wife
uh returning to united kingdom to face
justice there's a heartbreaking case
i've been lazing of course with the
family
and what we've said is that we would ask
the new administration its position on
the expedition request their position
hasn't changed
but we've also wanted to be clear and
the president uh the prime minister
discussed it with the president
uh here at canberra's bay that there
ought to be no
obstacles if you like politically to the
lawyers the cps talking to and so
coolest is lawyers there's no no
objection to them having a conversation
to see whether a virtual trial
could be done which can ensure
accountability and some measure of
solace for the family
and that's uh and that's what has been
agreed did you raise the question of
extradition with president biden
the prime minister did yes he asked
president biden
whether it would be possible to
extradite this individual
from the united states to britain so
both myself with
secretary of state lincoln but also the
pm with the president and of course at
official level
have tested very carefully whether the
fundamental position
on the extradition request has changed
it hasn't we've pressed this
but equally if that is not possible and
we've made our
clear our position clear there's been a
denial of justice we want to see
the obstacles removed that at least uh
the lawyers on all side
can discuss whether it's possible to
have a virtual trial and i think that's
a step forward
alongside the civil suit that i've been
supporting that the family have been
taking
in america geopolitics now um
the american president is going to meet
mr putin later on this week
henry kissinger says in the new book of
essays by gordon brown
that we're heading for a new cold war
between liberal democracies like ours
and authoritarians russia and china
and you actually in your integrated
review say that
russia will remain the most acute direct
threat to the united kingdom
do you agree with kissinger new cold war
no i don't quite like the analogy
because it looks back and we had a
bipolar world in those days effectively
ussr in the us
with its allies and we have a much more
multi-polar world today
but what i do see is the threat that
russia poses on the border with ukraine
with the build-up of troops
uh the the use of a chemical weapon on
alexei navalny hot on the heels of what
we saw in salisbury
uh its use of cyber attacks in a way
which is totally different from the cold
war
we're seeing cyber not just from russia
and not just from the russian state used
to attack schools
hospitals we've got to adapt to the new
threats that we face
we will do so by being absolutely clear
with russia and other hostile
states that we will hold them to account
and apply cost
for their malign behavior equally we
would like to get the relationship onto
a better footing the door of
uh diplomacy is always a jar always open
for better behavior
i noticed in that answer you didn't
mention china now um it's because you
asked me about russia
i know i said that you picked out russia
as a specific threat
but the americans clearly are more
worried about china which is
uh but the internet but let's let's
integrated review is littered with how
we will deal with china well well
let's talk about china um did you
discuss
uh as i think the head of the world
health organization has suggested
have you discussed the wuhan uh leak
or alleged leak this weekend uh i
haven't personally but of course it's
created uh part of the backdrop and
officials have been comparing notes on
this
if you're asking me whether we think on
the balance of probabilities if you like
that it originated in a lab
our best information for now is that it
didn't but we don't have all the answers
that's why
internationally we wanted the review to
be able to go in
to china to get all the answers to have
all the cooperation so we have the full
picture
rather than these possible potential
plausible options but on balance we do
not believe
that it came from a laboratory we think
it's much more likely
to have been to have jumped if you like
from animals to humans
can i come back to very briefly at the
end to an issue that
looked like was going to be a big
question last week which is the foreign
aid
budget which um you
you avoided let's put it that way but
it's going to come back
here is the issue that andrew mitchell
and other rebel
tory mps are raising is it
right is it the right priority for the
government to be putting
yet more money into defence and so on
but taking effectively four billion
out of what was anticipated in
foreign aid doesn't that mean you can
send more troops to mali
but you will be withdrawing money from
the girls education you talked about
from water uh clean water programs and
so on
actually doesn't that really
create a problem for us we're not
exercising the soft power we should
because we're putting the money in the
wrong place well look i don't accept the
binary
uh siloing of what we do for security of
countries from their
uh the soft power and the aid we put in
you gave the example of mali we put in
300 extra uk troops precisely to
stabilize
not for any particular raw direct
national security threat to the uk
but to stabilize that clinics in that
region now you then ask me about girls
education
actually at this um summit we've
announced 430 million pounds for the
global partnership for education that is
the biggest donation we've ever made now
of course because of the impact of the
pandemic on the public finances we've
had
we've had to re-prioritize i think
people at home would think it was odd
if we were re-prioritizing other budgets
but we didn't even look at the
international budgets but we're putting
in 10 billion
pounds in aid this year we're leading by
example the third biggest g7
uh global contributor and if you look at
this communique out at two o'clock
you'll see the good that global britain
could do foreign thank you very much for
your time
this morning we're going to turn now
to labour's international development
shadow emily thornbury
i beg your pardon the international
trade secretary
uh emily emily thornbury what did you
make of what the
foreign secretary had to say
particularly
on the issue of that we just um ended
there
on foreign aid and spending
well i personally think that it is
embarrassing more than embarrassing it
is simply wrong
for us to be the only country in the g7
nations around that table that's
actually cutting our aid budget
at a time like this i think that of
course we have to be doing more work in
relation to vaccines
and we should be starting with a bit of
international leadership which is
how do we make sure that we increase the
amount of vaccine that's available
but that is that is just not the same
issue as ensuring that we continue to
invest in the poorest countries
and allow them to lift themselves up at
a time like this
with this pandemic for example it is
obvious that the
health systems of many countries are
simply not up to an adequate
when it comes to being able to give out
the vaccine even if it was available
so it shows once more how important it
is that we continue to do
the right thing and invest in in
international
aid do you think that
um you heard the prime minister talk
yesterday
about building back uh in a gender
neutral way in a
more feminine way um do you agree with
that
and do you think that uh they this is
what they're putting forward is a way
of achieving that
i don't really understand what he's
talking about to be honest with you i
think what we should be doing is of
course we should be building back in a
way which is better we should be much
more
aware of the threat of climate change
that is the single biggest threat that
we face
and i think that when people look back
on this g7 they will be looking at it
and thinking
the optics were great cornwall has never
looked better with brilliant having a
different type of
president coming over you know so much
was going the right way but did we
really
use it as much as we could have to what
extent is this a wasted opportunity
so did we do enough in relation to
vaccines did we actually get some action
to increase the amount of supply did we
really step
up in the way that we must do as
attenborough has been warning us this
morning to be able to step up and do
something
about climate change adequately not just
talking about what we can do with our
own countries
but actually how are we what are we
going to do internationally what are we
going to do about ensuring that we
that the corporations finally pay the
right amount of tax
and frankly they're not and even this
agreement is frankly meager compared to
what it could be so
i think g7 could have been so much more
now is that feminine is that masculine i
don't really care to be honest with you
trevor what i care about is climate
change
i care about making sure we've got
vaccines that i make and i'm care about
corporations paying their way
the pro
forgive me there's a delay here so i'm
slightly missing what you're saying but
that's okay
but um are you supportive of the prime
minister's
one billion jabs target
i kind of feel as though it's missing
the point i think that
you know if we say you know we will hand
over our spare vaccines that isn't
really
the issue is something else you know the
issue is that we as a
as a globe are not making enough vaccine
we don't have enough factories around
the world strategically placed
making enough vaccines and being able to
step up and increase production
in the end otherwise if we don't do that
then we will continue to be saying oh
should this group have it should that
group have it have we handed over enough
we need to make sure that we are
producing enough as a world
so that when we are all talking about we
may i hope we don't but we may
in the autumn be talking about the need
for top-ups and all of us to have
top-ups
we may i hate to say in five years time
be talking about another pandemic
one thing we know is that we weren't
prepared as a world for this pandemic
we need to make sure that we have a
strategy
agreed internationally on what it is
that we're going to do next
not just talking about how much do we
have to spare that we can share with
others
that really isn't addressing the
fundamental problem
labor in the end accepted the northern
ireland
protocol
where do you think we've got to in this
summit
the prime minister island this morning
told
sky news that he thought that there is a
practical arrangement available
but um the government is saying that the
eu
is being overly bureaucratic do you buy
that
i think we just need to get this sorted
out i think it's completely ridiculous
i think that there are plenty of ways it
can be sorted out and the government
needs to step up and do it many things
have been suggested to it
and we need to have a veterinary
agreement with the eu we don't have one
at the moment
i personally think that the swiss model
is probably the best one that we should
have
we should just get on with it we should
we should understand that when we sign
up to international agreements
they are legally binding documents and
they need to be taken seriously
and we have to find a pragmatic way
through this i'm not saying
that the european union isn't being
petty i'm not saying that the number of
stops on the border
are frankly ridiculous but they are
sticking within the letter of the law
and we need to find a solution to that
and solutions are available
we just need to step back take a deep
breath and look beyond the sausages
and think you know what is the policy
that needs to be fixed and there are
plenty of things out there
and as i say a veterinary agreement
along the lines that the swiss had with
the
european union seems to me to be a
solution but there are plenty of others
you know a whole panoply of different
things for them to pick they just need
to get on with it
emily thought would be though isn't this
the remainer
in you speaking essentially saying well
look you know it's all a bit difficult
but if the eu really want to bear down
we don't want to have a fight
we just have to be a rule taker in this
situation
now look the united states has a better
veterinary agreement with the european
union than we
do we don't have one we don't have an
agreement as to what food needs to cross
the border and i tell you why
it's because the government wants to
have as much flexibility as possible
when it comes to potential other trade
deals so they want to
have the potential to lower our farm
standards and our food standards
in order to be able to accommodate other
future trade deals
frankly i think they have got this
completely the wrong way around what we
should be doing
is looking at what is in britain's
interests they have always said that
they will not lower our food and farming
standards
beyond below that that there is in the
european union so if that's right
why can't we just agree that with the
european union because
they want to keep their options open and
they want in future to have the
potential
to lower food standards particularly
because they're after a trade deal with
the united states
and the irony is here we have the united
states president
saying do you know what the most
important thing is not a trade deal
between britain
and the united states the most important
thing is the good friday agreement
and we in america are prioritizing that
and we think that you and britain should
be doing that too
and i agree big choice tomorrow big
choice tomorrow june the 21st should
we lift the restrictions given that
actually a lot of countries vaccinated
um
the businesses are crying out or are you
leaning now towards caution on the
labour side
i'm so sorry i didn't hear that question
trevor do you mind asking it again
i uh no problem i was asking you
we have this big decision about june the
21st where is labour standing now
do you say that we should go ahead lift
the restrictions
free businesses who are crying out and
so on
or are you now inclined given the data
towards caution
we have always been inclined towards
more than inclined we have always said
that we must follow the scientific
advice and the scientific advice
is pretty clear that we can't have
a lifting of the lockdown at the moment
there needs to be
more of a delay because of the variant
and because of all the other reasons
i just want to be confident that the
prime minister is listening to that
scientific agreement
you know you do look back and wonder
whether
now you wonder what on earth were they
did they think they were doing
by not closing the borders at the time
when they should have i have no doubt
there was no scientific
advice telling them not to close the
borders because they should have
particularly when the delta variant
started and
you know you wonder why it was that they
kept the border open for example with
india
and yet closed the border with pakistan
and bangladesh
i think it was because boris johnson
continued with the fantasy that he was
going to be
right until the last minute that he was
going to be allowed to go to india
and and sign some sort of pre-trade deal
it's another example
of putting trade deals and standing in
front of flags and signing them up and
and and so on before the interests of
our country
trade deals ought to be about what are
the interests of our in our country and
make sure our trade deals reflect that
and build on it not the other way around
emily thornbee thank you and thank you
for coping with the delay here
thank you well thank you for coping with
the delays
let's let us turn now to a veteran of
g7 summit the former prime minister
gordon brown who has published essays
uh on international and other policies
uh but i want to start if i may
gordon brown by
you're the man with experience of these
international gatherings
if you were um in boris johnson's shoes
today
where would you be leading in a way
given what you uh experienced back in
2000
2009 what lessons that would
would you have taken from that period uh
to apply
to today's international crisis
yeah it's up to the chairman and that's
boris johnson to lead
the others would respond but i think
this summit will go down as a missed
opportunity
a missed opportunity when we needed 11
billion vaccines
we've only got offered a plan for 1
billion
we needed 50 billion dollars allocated
to the vaccination of the world
and only five billion dollars and i
think this some of them afraid will also
go down
as an unforgivable moral failure when
the richest countries are sitting around
the table with the power to do something
about it
now that we've discovered the vaccine we
have not set out the comprehensive plan
that will deliver vaccination by the
middle of next year
boris johnson said on sunday that this
would be the greatest feat in medical
history he said it was the great
challenge of postwar history
well i'm afraid there will be smiles but
there are not solutions
millions of people will go unvaccinated
and thousands of people
i'm afraid will die
to be fair this is not just
boris johnson of course uh mr biden mr
macron
uh mitsun merkel they've all agreed
to this uh this is um if you want to put
it that way a comprehensive
global failure then isn't it well
mrs merkel and mr trudeau did a letter
to the financial times only two days ago
in which they
said they wanted the g7 to share the
cost 67
of the cost which is about 50 billion
over two years of vaccinating
and protecting the world with testing
and protective equipment
now i'll wait to see the final
communicate but it looks as if
there is a huge gap between what boris
johnson promised last sunday
and what is actually being delivered and
i'm afraid it is a
gap in funding and i'm afraid it also
comes back to the british cuts in
overseas aid that we're not prepared
to put up enough money to deal with
problems that the world faces
even when at the benefits in extra
economic activity if the world gets back
to growth and trade uh far outweigh the
costs of doing this
and and so boris johnson really has got
to think are we to leave this problem
uh to the g20 to next year or the year
after
because on the basis of the evidence i
see the whole world will not be
vaccinated by the middle of 2022
and we will have a huge problem of a
division between the richest countries
that are safe and the poorest countries
that are not safe
but then the problem will come back to
haunt the richest countries because we
all have contagion
spreading that may hurt even the people
who are vaccinated
because of mutations and variants
is it just a matter of funding though we
heard the foreign secretary saying
earlier
that this is also a question of the
mechanism so for example
do you really trust the world health
organization
to be able to uh dispense
that level of vaccination the 11 billion
or whatever number you choose
that you think is ideal well it's at
least 11 billion
and it's not just the who is saying that
every government that's involved in
what's called kovacs
accepts that these are the figures you
know what we did in britain was the
right way to do when we're facing the
problems of the world
what you do is you put up the money you
pre-order the vaccines
you then build up the manufacturing
capacity and then you have factories in
this case in every continent
and unless you have this virtuous circle
which starts
with the guarantee of funding then you
will not solve the problem
and i fear that the g7 has not only
missed this opportunity
but it will take months before the world
gets back to discussing this again
in the most coherent way we need a plan
we don't have yet a plan
we're going to have a shortage of
vaccines over the summer and we're still
not going to meet the 11 billion
that most people who look at this
seriously say is needed 1 billion
is welcome but faced with the need for
11 billion
really the g7 the richest countries
should have done much more
in your book um which is uh called seven
ways to change the world
you said that the pan after the pandemic
is over we'll still have
260 million children not in education
but the problems that we're facing
can't all just be put down to covid can
they even if the disease
makes those problems worse well the
sustainable development goals that
britain signed up to every country
signed up to say
everybody in education by the year 2030.
now britain has done a lot in the past
we've offered
to fund the education of 40 million with
the g7 countries
but that's 40 million girls but there
will be 400
million girls leaving school or not at
school
over the next few years leaving school
without qualifications
so again we're dealing with only a
fraction of the problem it's the gap
trevor between
the promises that the international
community makes boris johnson made on
sunday
and the reality that when it comes to it
yes they'll all be smiles at the end of
the summit
but where's the substance when we need
to get the vaccinations in place
we need to get children back to school
we need obviously also to deal with this
escalating problem of poverty around the
world there are 150 million more people
in poverty
since the start of the crisis and that's
150 million people who
don't really have the food that they
need to survive
a quick question about domestic policy
does it were
um the irish prime minister told us this
morning that he thought
a solution to the northern ireland
protocol
issue was possible where what would you
be proposing were you
in the prime minister's seat today
this can only be solved by people
getting around the table and talking
about it
uh there are difficulties in
administration uh but the protocol
will not change in my view over the next
few months you know when i was prime
minister even at the height of the
financial crisis i spent days in
northern ireland talking to all the
parties
listening to their complaints their
queries answering some of their problems
and this needs time it needs a prime
minister who is prepared to spend the
time
speaking to people in every part of
northern ireland as well as speaking to
the government of ireland
and the european union and it can't be
done simply by a few statements that
the protocol may need to be looked at
again or alternatively that someone else
has got to solve the problem for him
he's got to spend the time and it's only
the prime minister i'm afraid
and it does come back to who's in charge
you can't solve this northern ireland
problem without the prime minister
engaging it
with the fullest attention that will be
needed as the g7 summit finishes
but subtly without any
great fanfare the truth is that
what they say in northern ireland or
some people say in northern ireland
is that this is all undermining northern
ireland's place
in the union do you not fear that
drift to separate separatism
well i think boris johnson again has got
to understand that this is a union of
england scotland wales and northern
ireland and each part of that union has
got its own
cultural traditions its own
sensitivities its own needs and its own
aspirations
and you've got to work at this the job
of a prime minister
and perhaps he's the only person that
can do it he or she
is to unite the whole country to bring
people together
i believe there should be a forum that
brings together the nations and the
regions in a more systematic way
so that common problems are discussed
chaired by the prime minister
but you can't assume that the united
kingdom is going to hold together
if you don't work at it and that demands
efforts cooperation
policies for cooperation instruments for
cooperation
and of course a determination that
cooperation is going to work
in your book um if we can return to
the global situation henry kissinger
talks about a new cold war between
liberal democracies and
authoritarian states by which he means
russia and
china do you agree with that analysis
and if so what can we do to avoid it
or is it inevitable i think he's right i
think he's right about the risk
and the risk is even greater than he's
describing it's one world two systems
it's not just a cold war it's people
moving in a completely different
direction
one international monetary fund for the
west one for asia
one world bank for the west one for asia
one currency
or set of currencies dominating in the
west one in asia
and i think we've got to avoid that i
have always stood out against the human
rights policies of china
we had a human rights dialogue with
china but i've always also said
that where we can agree like on climate
change like actually
a plan to vaccinate the world uh like on
on dealing with some of the huge global
problems we face including economic
growth in the poorest countries we have
to find a way to work together i suspect
that's what
joe biden wants to do amidst the the
fiery rhetoric against china
he believes there are areas where you
can cooperate and you should
but also areas where you've got to say
very clearly we disagree entirely with
what you're doing
and we will try to persuade you to
change your mind but you have to
concentrate
in a world as fragile as this where we
have huge problems
that are global we have to concentrate
on finding ways to work together where
we can
okay we have we have a very short time
but i i don't think i can let you go
without asking you a question
about scotland and labor um
no it's not an argument that labor
probably is not where it would like to
be
in polls and elections looking at the
recent
local elections the prospect of losing
battley and so on but a big issue for
the laid party
is its position in scotland which is
dire what should labour be doing
to re restore and regain its status in
scotland
well we've got to show that we're both
the party of social justice
and that the scottish national party are
not delivering that despite all their
promises
and we're the party of solidarity in in
in this interdependent world
there is no future in nations that are
neighboring nations fighting each other
and i fear 50 years of conflict between
scotland and england
if we don't get these problems sorted
out so we have got to be the party
of solidarity of talking about empathy
reciprocity cooperation
and sharing and of course we've found
during the vaccination effort
that when we cooperate we get things
done british
pre-purchasing scottish delivery in
scotland of the vaccine
now that's a way forward on health but
it's a way forward on climate change
which cannot be solved without countries
working together and the recovery
where jobs are going to be needed to be
created and we need
all the resources of the united kingdom
in every part of the united kingdom put
to work
gordon brown thank you very much for
your time this morning
thank you trevor well i referred to it
uh on
a couple occasions already uh the irish
prime minister
uh miguel martin has spoken on the issue
of northern ireland and the eu
and he did that in an interview with my
sky news colleague
david blevins here is what the irish
prime minister
had to say he said the uk government
said it was uh surprised the eu was
enforcing the protocol those checks in
the rsc as emphatically as it is
does that surprise you um well it does
in a sense that i think the the
uk government aren't no illusions about
where the eu is coming from in relation
to the protocol but the european union
is willing and
uh very engaged in endeavoring to find a
resolution to the issues that have been
raised
uh in respect of the the northern
ireland ireland protocol
and in my view the channels do exist to
get this resolved
and in particular the sethkovich frost
process should be fully explored
and optimized to get an agreement and i
think uh the prospects
in my view if there's a will there on
both sides and there is a will there for
the european union said i know that
i detect from the british prime minister
boris johnson british government is
anxious to get a resolution of this
uh so i think we should we should walk
at it that's more hopeful than we've
heard for quite a while there's still a
lot of
points scoring going on over brexit so
is there not a danger of the politics
thwarting attempts to find solutions i
think we need to move beyond where we
are
i think from my understanding of a lot
of the technical issues that have been
discussed progress can be made on quite
a lot of the issues
i believe the us administration's
comments
last week which were released
are interesting as well and so far as
they deal with a significant issue that
would concern the british government i.e
the uh capacity to do a trade deal with
the united states
whilst also having an sps
arrangement between the european union
and the united kingdom and in my view
uh there's a legitimate issue there for
you your united kingdom government
but in our view an sps agreement would
deal with up to 80 percent of all of
these issues
and i think it's a surprise what uh
certainly exploring
in the fullest manner possible to what
extent do you understand the u.s
administration chastise the british
government
for the perceived threat at least to the
peace process
and do you believe president biden
perhaps has a further role to play in
help
helping to broker a solution i wouldn't
see it as a chastisement around that i
think the the
u.s president is very clear on restoring
the transatlantic relationship between
america and the european union and
america and the united kingdom
he sees uk europe and the u.s aligned on
the fundamentals
of democracy freedom of speech that's
very important
and so he really wants the eu eu and the
uk to resolve this issue
he's also then of course as we know
absolutely committed to the good friday
agreement
the full working of the institutions of
the good friday agreement and he doesn't
want
discussions around the protocol uh to to
undermine the good friday agreement
and and he also wants to see full
engagement
and he believes as a way and a root as i
do to getting these issues resolved
and i think the big picture for him is
to be fully aligned
on the big issues of the day globally
between the eu america and the united
kingdom
and that really issues of this sort
should be should be started
you mentioned the good friday agreement
your government and indeed the eu has
repeatedly
argued that a border on the island of
ireland would pose a threat to the good
friday agreement
but with now thousands of loyalists
protesting at times on the streets some
of them asked
does a border in the rsc not pose just
as much of a threat to that agreement
well again i think
the nature of brexit has been
challenging in that respect
okay in terms of the absence of a
customs union and that but in our view
an sps agreement could deal with a lot
of the issues around food
animal welfare and and and and so on and
in my view given the challenges
given the necessity to reduce tensions
we've never seen the protocol as a
constitutional issue it doesn't in any
way
interfere with the constitutional status
of northern ireland that's defined and
articulated within the good fight
agreement we're very clear from the
irish government perspective on that
and but we do believe in seamless trade
on the island of ireland it makes sense
we believe in seeing this trade and so
far as we possibly can between united
kingdom and and northern ireland
we think northern ireland's economy can
develop over time
through its access to the uk market
obviously but also
access to the european union market if
you look at the dairy industry for
example
i mean bill comes north south uh
seamlessly
without any issues that's important for
ulster farmers it's important for
for the industry both sides of the
border and the second a practical
trade that we want to encourage we do
acknowledge that issues have arisen
that are causing concern we believe
those issues can be dealt with
in the context of the discussions
between the european union and the
united kingdom and we're willing to play
a helpful role in that
time is not on your side now if there is
no deal by the first of july
and the british government unilaterally
for a third time
extends the grace period this time for
chilled mates to avoid this so-called
sausage war what way would you expect
the eu to respond to that i think it'll
be very problematic because it's not
about sausages per se
it really is about the fact that an
agreement had been entered into not too
long ago
signed off by the british government
with the european union the trade and
cooperation agreement
including the withdrawal agreement and
the protocol and that creates a
if just consistent unilateral deviation
from that agreement
that clearly undermines the broader
relationship between the european union
and the united kingdom uh which is in
nobody's interest
uh and therefore that's why the uk with
the eu you have to work very hard now
in the coming weeks i know the european
union are anxious to resolve this
and want to resolve it but that they
need to see
a similar reciprocity from from the uk
side
so just to be clear you believe sps
agreement is neither solution
and would you be hopeful that because
president biden has assured the british
government
that that wouldn't prevent a trade deal
that they may now
consider that seriously i think it is a
significant part of the solution
i think they should consider it very
seriously and i think it could lead
um to a breakthrough on this just one
final question
i'm conscious that arlene foster is
preparing to formally resign
as first minister of northern ireland
how concerned are you
that her ousting as the eup leader could
destabilize the power sharing
administration
first of all i want to thank arlene and
they warm tribute to her for her
commitment to public life into public
service
over so many years and particularly
laterally in our capacity as first
minister and leader to dup
i had a good relationship with arlene
over the years bought when i was
for foreign affairs over a decade ago in
the context of the devolution of justice
and i wish arlene well now uh in terms
with her family in terms of
the next stage of our journey in life uh
and i've also met with edwin putz
i had a good meeting with him in dublin
last week
and i believe that he is committed to
the institutions of the good friday
agreement to
uh fulfilling all of the obligations on
that we all have
collectively uh so my i'm
of a view that we can you know safeguard
the institutions and progress the
various sets of relationships that are
encompassed by the
good fight agreement itself so i think
uh you know there have been many twists
and turns
in terms of the peace process in terms
of politics
in northern ireland the island of
ireland and between britain and ireland
and it falls on those of us who are in
positions of influence and positions of
leadership
uh to engage with each other uh and to
work together to resolve
the challenges that come our way they
should thank you for your time you're
very welcome indeed thank you
ireland's prime minister mahal martin
speaking i thought rather optimistically
to our colleague david blevins now the
foreign secretary dominic raab
when he spoke to me earlier was pretty
cagey on the issue
of reopening on june 21st but i think
the prime minister gave a pretty strong
signal earlier on this weekend that
he was aiming to be cautious
now it all comes as cobit cases start to
climb again
and uh new surge but potentially
uh fueled by the delta
variant first identified in india
well to talk more about whether june
21st
is going to be freedom day or not we're
joined by the government's
independent advisor encoded with
ethnicity
dr rahib ali
dr ali do you think that progress
uh along the road map has now been
derailed
by the delta variant
uh good morning trevor and thank you
time on the program this morning
just before i answer that trevor i just
wanted to mention something about the
general approach that i've taken
you know throughout this pandemic as to
whether we should have
uh ongoing restrictions or lifting
restrictions and
the approach i've always taken is that
we have to look at the overall kind of
benefits and harms of a particular
policy and we're trying to minimize
overall harm so of course
you know there are potential harms from
covert if it's allowed to get out of
control in cases and hospitalization and
debts increase but of course there are
also potential harms
from ongoing restrictions and over the
last 18 months i've consistently called
for restrictions generally to be lifted
earlier particularly last summer when i
felt that schools were closed
for too long and we could have reopened
sooner so having said all that
uh it's true that the situation has
really changed over the last two weeks i
mean two weeks ago when i was asked the
same question
i said it was just too early to tell we
needed to look at what data would
materialize over these two weeks but
unfortunately over the last
few days what has become very clear is
that cases because of the delta variant
which really has transformed the
situation
cases are increasing rapidly doubling
almost every week in some places but the
key factor is now the hospitalizations
are also increasing
fortunately not at the same rate as we
saw back in waves one on waves two
and but they are increasing uh
sufficient rate that we need to be very
cautious going forward
what would you like the prime minister
to say when he speaks tomorrow
it sounds like you think you would urge
delay
and if so for how long
so the reason i think a delay is
inevitable now is because as i said what
we're seeing now in
hospitals hospitals extremely busy at
the moment the emergency departments
last month where the business they have
been
you know for years um because a huge
backlog of patients that didn't come in
during the the peaks
particularly the second wave partly
because they were worried about catching
covet and also because they didn't want
to put pressure on the nhs
so having a huge number of people coming
to the emergency departments as well as
dealing with this huge waiting list and
backlog
and so even a relatively small increase
in hospital emissions
for covid will have a significant impact
on all our non-covered patients all our
cancer patients heart patients etc
and we really can't afford you know to
for those people to suffer anymore
they've already suffered
enough over the last 18 months so what i
expect
the prime minister uh to say is that
based on that data
unfortunately a a delay is needed to
make sure
that we don't get to a situation again
where the nhs is unable to provide care
to all its patients i mean this this
slogan that we've had over the last you
know 18 months of protecting nhs it's
not about protecting hospitals or
doctors or workers here
it's really about protecting our
non-covered patients that's really the
key
and that's what we need to ensure we
don't get into that problem again
and the second point really in essence
what you you're sorry
so carry on and it's okay um i was gonna
say the irreversibility really
is key as well as the prime minister's
stress i think the worst thing for all
of us
and for the economy the hospitality for
our mental and physical health would be
to go backwards you know to
to re to go back to before we were
before step three at least with step
three we're able to visit no family
and friends and to me and to go out et
cetera so the last thing we want
is to have to go backwards
do you think that there is um any value
in for example uh closing schools at
this point
no certainly not i think children have
suffered
hugely over the last uh 18 months and
one of the main things i've always
stressed is that schools should stay
open as long as possible and i would
have wanted them to reopen earlier
last year but the other point related to
that is that if cases continue to
increase even without hospitalizations
that has a significant impact on the
number of children in school we saw in
bolton before half term
a third of children were off school and
certainly we don't want that happen
across the country
so by keeping cases as low as possible
in the coming four weeks while schools
are open
that maximizes the chance for all
children to be in school until the end
of term and you ask me about the amount
of time that's required for this delay
i mean partly because of schools partly
because of what's likely to happen with
the nhs
you know it seems that a four-week delay
would be optimal
it allows us to vaccinate millions more
people both with first and second doses
and the good news is that you know in
places like bolton we saw that where we
increased vaccination and testing and
people took
more care we were able to bring this
third wave under control and although
hospitals did increase
they didn't get as high as the the
second or first wave
dr ali thank you very much pretty clear
message there delay
keep children in school and we'll get
out of it thank you very much indeed
thank you so let's return to the g7
summit here in cornwall gordon brown was
pretty damning
about the failure of the world's leaders
to do enough to get vaccines to the
developing
world that follows criticism from a
number of conservative
mps uh in the last couple of weeks about
plans to cut
the foreign aid budget um another way
that the uk
supports poorer nations well leading the
charge amongst those conservative mps is
the former international
development secretary andrew mitchell
and he
joins us now andrew mitchell
um what did you think of what
dominic robb said earlier on about
why he thought that the billion vaccines
on the schedule that they're
proposing is pretty much the best you're
going to get
well i think the summit has been
extremely successful
in focusing on the key issues and i
think
the prime minister deserves great credit
for having got the
other six leaders of the richest
countries in the world
to focus on the things that really
matter particularly in the middle of a
a global pandemic so i think as far as
it goes
those issues are the ones which we now
need to
uh really push forward and the um really
the question is this
uh is there enough money these are the
richest countries in the world
is there enough money to drive forward
the vaccination of the world which is
the
prime minister's ambition and upon which
our national interests and our welfare
depend in the future
um and i think the jury so far is out on
that we'll see whether or not the summit
communique uh
commits the richest countries to step up
to the plate
and of course i have to say it's been
more difficult for the prime minister to
do that
when in the previous two uh global
summits
uh in in birmingham and in glen eagles
in britain
britain really led from the front on on
development on tackling poverty
on bringing the world together on that
agenda it's been more difficult to do
that this time
because britain is the only g7 country
that is reversing that is cutting its
aid
when all the others are either
increasing it or at least
keeping it at the same level and the
impact of that is very severe and it
will impact not only
our ability to achieve these objectives
but also to tackle the
global pandemic one example i would give
you is this that
we are we are slashing spending on clean
water and sanitation
which is actually absolutely critical to
combating
the pandemic and as a result of this 80
percent cut by britain
on water and sanitation 10 million of
the poorest people
will not this year get access to it
i i put that point actually to dominic
rob earlier on and he said well
you know we have to balance the needs of
the economy
and of course security where we're
spending more money on uh
soldiers he used we use the example of
mali
and uh we're doing as much as we can do
um
do you buy that
well you know the in the scheme of
things this cut
is one percent of what we spent tackling
kovid quite rightly last year it's one
percent and it's the only cut that was
announced in the
otherwise excellent comprehensive
spending review last november
and it's not a cut we have to make and
in in comparison with anything else as i
said it's a very small amount
of money but the impact it's going to
have not just
you know on on the poorest people in the
world which will be
huge but also on britain's reputation
and britain's ability
to move the dial on these very important
international issues will be
be great and i i heard what the foreign
secretary said about
mali but i thought that the point you
made was a very good one if you put
200 300 troops in harm's way in
in mali but you also scrap much of the
international development program
across that area of sahel which means
you take away the hope
and the optimism of of women to be able
to get
access to birth control of children to
go to school of
of of communities that are teetering on
the edge of starvation
you take that away it actually acts as a
sort of recruiting sergeant for the
terrorist message and and that's not a
good position when you're putting
british troops into that sort of
uh theater it sounds like you are
putting the government
on a warning and that you are going to
be back
with an attempt to restore that 0.7
percent
uh development budget 0.7 of the
of gross domestic product development
budget that the government
has reduced to 0.5 is that right you're
going to be back
for another go
yes we are and the government should
should accept the olive branch
we suggested in parliament which is to
bring back the 0.7 from january
next year when the economy will have
rebounded we've seen the
excellent economic news thanks to the
chancellor's good stewardship of our
economy uh in even in today's uh papers
um but we've got to be really really
careful about this and the government
should listen to its friends we are
supporters of the government we are
campaigners for the conservative party
we are people who've got the
government's best interests at heart and
we urge the government to listen to what
the house of commons is saying
the government does not command the
house of commons on this issue last week
they would have lost a vote had it gone
ahead now
the government should listen to what its
friends are saying accept the olive
branch
and bring back the point seven as we all
promised at the last general election
as soon as possible and preferably in
january next year
some of the government's other friends
are not saying what you're saying
what they're saying is we can't afford
to spend the money that we need to get
our children to catch up for the
education
that they've lost in the last 18 months
and
in the red wall what they're saying red
wall seats
what the the tories have just recently
uh acquired
that what they're saying is why are we
spending money
on other nations children when we can't
even
educate our own
i i am very clear that we need to do
both those two things and
you know we've been joined by uh quite a
large number of brilliant colleagues
from these red wall seats the
boris has spread the dna of the tory
party
very well into the red wall seats we've
won seats we've never had before and
i campaigned in some of them in the west
midlands and when i asked people whether
they were
uh voting conservative they said no i'm
voting for boris so
you know he has widened the tory party's
dna
very well but we mustn't forget the
lessons we learned in 2015 it took the
tory party 23 years to win an overall
majority in parliament 1992-2015
and the reason we won in 2015 was
because the tory party's dna
embraced internationalism it embraced uh
the very important
message to many people on international
development and on the importance of
tackling these
quite extraordinary discrepancies of
wealth and opportunity
which disfigure our world in which our
generations
are able to do so much about um and that
that meant that all those liberal seats
and people who were sort of on the
margins of the tory party
they came and they supported the tory
message because it was a broad church
and what we've got to be very careful
about is we don't add this extra
very important dna at one end and lose
it at the other end because
we turn our backs on two decades where
britain
under both parties it hasn't been a sort
of labor or conservative policy
it's been a policy of britain to to
really
lead the world on tackling international
development that's not only about money
it's also about the
policy generation from our great
universities and
think tanks but britain has had that
leadership centrally and it's been very
noticeable you know you only have to
look at the briefings
during this g7 summit that that
leadership and that thrust
has not been there because we've broken
our promise on the point seven
but andrew mitchell um you you you're a
former
chief whip you can count the numbers as
well as anybody else
and actually boris johnson has a bigger
majority than any conservative leader
for
some time and actually he is where head
in the polls
is your real worry here um a longer term
one that the cut to international
development money will make the tories
look
like what people used to say they are
the nasty party
uh i think that the tory party is full
of volunteers who are part of the great
ngo alliance crack the crisis which
you know has got more than 10 million
supporters and often you know
conservative
uh branch officers are also the people
who help run oxfam
and save the children another great
charities throughout our country we are
we are a big-hearted broad party that
really care about these issues and and i
worry that in the
in the rather mean and almost dickensian
approach to
our development spend well we've cut it
in the middle of a pandemic in breach of
the promises we all made
all 650 of us at the last general
election
arguably in breach of the law very
senior lawyers in britain have said that
this
this is unlawful because it's not
missing the target it's changing the
target 2.5
and also the promises we made to the
united nations and on the floor of the
general assembly
i i think it's very bad for britain's
image but above all
it's bad for the party and it's bad for
our reputation
and our ability to move the dial in some
very wretched and poor parts of the
world
very last quick question about june 21st
because it's a big signal
whether the government decides it wants
to co-exist and
will open up or whether it is going to
be cautious and
stick keep to tr try to suppress the
virus even
further where are you standing on this
are you looking forward to
weddings with more than 30 people and
being out in a barbecue where you don't
have to wear a mask
well my own my own lovely daughter has
had to delay her wedding now for the
second year so she's had she's gonna
have to wait two years now before she's
able to marry her partner so i feel very
very very strongly for people whose
weddings have been postponed
uh in that way and i feel desperately
sorry for the hospitality industry
throughout the royal town of sutton
coalfield which has
suffered so grievously but i think we
must follow the science and i have
great faith that the prime minister will
reach the right conclusions so i'm
looking forward
to hearing what he what his judgment is
tomorrow
andrew mitchell thank you very much
indeed